[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages it's time to see what's
making headlines with the writer and
broadcaster polly mckenzie and the
political editor of the scottish son
rachel watson they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight so let's
take a look at what is on some of those
front pages we'll start with the daily
express which says the prime minister
has vowed to win the next general
election
that says tory mp's plot to have boris
johnson removed according to the
telegraph
the mirror's headline is directed at mr
johnson it says as you can see go now
now tomorrow's mail leads with a call
from the health secretary sergeant javis
to reveal an alleged pact between the
labor and liberal democrat parties the
ft leads with the u.s supreme court's
decision to overturn roe versus wade
which would deprive millions of american
women the ability to get an abortion
well the sun says katie price has
avoided a jail sentence after breaking a
restraining order and a reminder by
scanning that qr code that you see on
your screen right now during the program
you can check out the front pages of the
papers while you watch along with us
well let's bring in our guests joined by
the writer and broadcaster polly
mckenzie and the political editor of the
scottish son rachel watson polly rachel
good evening to you thank you very much
for being with us let's get straight
into it and we'll start with the front
page of the times now after that by
election defeat and boris johnson losing
oliver dowden conservative party
chairman there is now a new threat the
times say uh polly tell us some more
about what the reporting tells us
well we know that boris johnson won a
vote of confidence uh in his leadership
but by a much smaller margin than he
would have hoped and and his predecessor
theresa may secured even though she then
was gone within six months so those
plotters the 148 mps who did vote no
confidence in the prime minister
and potentially some others who have
been a bit spooked by what's happened in
those two by-elections
are now thinking about what can they do
in order to potentially unseat um boris
johnson um
previously the speculation was that uh
led by david frost um the you know
former brexit minister was that they
would be trying something on in the
autumn around party conference time but
they're now looking at how to gain
control
of the executive of the 1922 committee
the committee of backbench mps because
if they control the executive um which
is having elections soon um then the
executive can change the rules and mean
that boris johnson can vote can face
another vote of confidence
uh at some point before his kind of year
of protection is out so that's the kind
of the gossip going around among the
rebels in westminster
but equally on the other side the the
parliamentary private secretaries are
being encouraged to also
get involved in those elections for the
1922 committee to try and shore up boris
johnson's position uh rachel as uh polly
said that's the gossip but it's uh being
quite widely reported isn't this idea
that they're going to try and change the
rules of the game of that 1922 committee
to make sure that this uh confidence
vote can be held in him again
yeah i think almost as soon as we had
the result from the last vote no
confidence that the prime minister just
won and there was chat that the rules
could be changed because i don't think
many people expected that there would be
148 that size of rebellion you know
spoken to boy politicians since then he
said they'd back the prime minister all
the way through partygate until they've
seen the size of the rebellion
in the commons so i think you know we've
heard about it since then i think what's
interesting about this times piece as
well that they have kind of dug into
that oliver dowden resignation today um
and have spoken to one minister who said
that you know he actually quit he saw
the writing on the wall he didn't want
to stick about
suggesting that there's other ministers
that could be looking at doing the same
thing you know jump before they're
pushed if boris johnson does try and
reshuffle his cabinet to get make that
more supportive and junior minister
positions as well um but they also this
minister is also suggesting that oliver
dowden has
left his position as chairman of the
party to go and run a leadership
campaign for rishi sooner the chancellor
who you know we all know would probably
like a chance to run for number 10 if
that came around okay certainly do all
right let's move on to the front page of
the mail if we can uh please uh polly
and rachel and this is a lineup um from
an interview that they've done with
health actually sergey javid who wants
uh
someone to tell the public the truth
about the anti-tory package says
apparent lib lab alliance has uh was
what dealt boris the double by election
blow uh
polly uh what's all this about because
whenever i get the chance to ask anyone
in the labour party you'll live dems
about any pact they say no no there's
nothing to see here
well i mean there isn't there isn't a
pact there's no agreement nothing's
written down
however it was really clear in those two
by-elections that the voters are pretty
sensible um hardly anyone voted labour
in timberton or holliston labour lost
their deposit hardly anyone voted lib
dem
in wakefield the lib dems lost their
deposit and that's partly because the
voters can just you know they can do
maths
and what's really interesting about this
moment that should not give the
conservatives comfort is that people
actually are willing to take any old
anyone but boris candidate and switch
their vote you know you've really got to
hate the incumbent
to be willing to sort of trade your vote
to
to any comma basically which is what we
saw happening um
but that doesn't mean that there's a
formal pact it does mean that if you
think forward to the general election
all of the parties especially the lib
dems actually very small party with tiny
resources in comparison with the others
they're not going to campaign hard in
every seat it would be mindless
stupidity to do so they get a campaign
in the places where they've got the best
prospects and the labour party is going
to campaign in the places where it's got
the best prospects why waste resources
sending whatever canvases out in
tiverton and hunterton in the next
general election when they could be down
the road in exeter defending a labor
seat or um down the road in bournemouth
trying to you know it's trying to take
ground off the conservatives it just
wouldn't make any sense
that's different right because in 2019
jeremy corbyn did try and target
anything to stop those people who
defected from labor via change you pay
to the lib dems to stop them getting
elected diverting resources from the
main fight against the conservatives but
jeremy corbyn was a fool yeah
okay
and polly uh i'm sorry rachel let's uh
in the reporting here on the front page
of the mail they talk about this lib lab
alliance but i think um you will agree
with me that perhaps the most important
pact if there is anyone to be done but
with that labour party would be with the
smp in scotland perhaps
yeah and i think uh just talking about
this kind of tactical voting where you
try and vote for the you know vote
someone out rather than vote someone in
in particular is something we've seen in
a number of elections here the liberal
democrats have benefited that benefited
from it and seats where they can you
know
anybody but the smp is work we saw the
pro-independent side i try and harness
that with more green vote um in the last
election as well so tackle voting is
something that has been used in scotland
and people become quite good at it
actually when you look at the election
results where that goes but yeah there
is chat and um you know will there if
there's a hung parliament at the next
general election for example could that
see a deal with labor and the smp this
is something that the conservatives have
spoken up they've talked about campaigns
over the last couple of general
elections and to voters you know do you
want the snp
and in power in some way in england as
well with uh with the pack the labour
party to get them into number 10. the
labour party repeatedly pushed this down
they say that they wouldn't do packs
kirsten said it and that star war the
scottish labour leader said that there
would be no deal and but you know i
spoke to john carter professor john
curtis few weeks ago who said if pierce
armour's got the option of number 10 or
having to resign because he's lost an
election or won't work with snp in a
hung parliament you know what's he going
to pick and so it could be a very
interesting next general election and
just pick up on that a little bit if you
can then polly i mean what do you think
voters would feel about the idea of
these kind of alliances you know
nothing's written down nothing formal
but
the knowledge that the parties are
working together
well i think the voters prefer to have
all of the options on the ballot paper
and to make their own choices and i
think that's in the vast majority of
circumstances what they'll see
you know back in 2015 when david cameron
won a majority he did so by precisely
what rachel's talking about real
scaremongering about the snp
about the lib dems
this the tagline was chaos under ed
miliband which you know we all know
sort of chuckle at given the
extraordinary chaos we have seen since
2015 under the succession of slightly
hopeless conservative prime ministers
but you i think the reality is that the
conservatives want to fight that message
again they know it worked for david
cameron they think it still works but i
i just think kind of chaos under-kissed
armor
doesn't
doesn't seem anywhere near as scary and
they have thrown so many rules out they
have done such chaotic government they
have lurched us through you know
i don't know lying to the queen and
proroguing parliament and so much stuff
that the idea that there's a threat from
chaos i i just don't think it's got that
electoral magic anymore perhaps not okay
uh polly rachel do appreciate that stay
with us because there's plenty more to
come from you we hope after the break
but uh still to come here on sky news
we'll take a look at that u.s supreme
court ruling on abortion rights it's
featured as you can see there on the
front page of the ft we'll get polly
rachel's opinion on that after
[Music]
hello and welcome back you're watching
the press preview i'm pleased to say
we're joined by the writer and
broadcaster polly mckenzie and the
political editor of the scottish son
rachel watson all right guys thanks for
being with us again all right let's look
at the front page of the ft the story
that we've been leading with all night
of course uh the supreme court um
looking down roe versus wade uh
polly we've heard um in our reporting
this morning both sides of this argument
it's another massive dividing line issue
in the united states but most concerning
for many people i guess will be the
rights of the women who've lost the
right to choose
yeah it's just it's devastating from the
kind of the personal tragedies that will
ensue from this and also from a sense of
the the toxic artisan nature
uh of politics in the us at the moment
um
you know at the heart of this for me
certainly is this idea of forcing women
to carry fetuses that they do not want
it's
the thought of being pregnant without
your consent is
so horrifying to me and you know let
alone when you talk about the number of
states who have uh no exemptions for
incest no exemption for
the health of the mother the life of the
mother
it's just
horrifying to think what will happen
because of course it will not ban
abortion you can ban abortion but
everywhere through history that that has
happened um
you just push abortion into the dark
places where it is unsafe and dangerous
for the women uh for their ability to
bear children in future you know there
was an amazing piece of writing by the
the author ursula le guin circulating
earlier um on twitter that i read and
never come across it before but talking
about how if she had had to have a child
when she got pregnant when she was at
university she would never have had her
other three children because she'd have
never met her husband and and so this
idea that you are saving lives when you
are actually putting so many lives at
risks it's just simply just it it's
heartbreaking and it has been done by a
process where a series of two presidents
who did not win the popular vote have
put in lifetime appointments to the
supreme court it you know it does feel
like american democracy is quite
profoundly broken well pick up on that
then if you can for us register i mean
what do you think this tells us about um
the future direction of the us i mean
there are calls to perhaps reform the
supreme court but that could enter in
some kind of arms race where both sides
whoever is in power change the court in
different ways
yeah and i think we've heard about
concerns
way back when donald trump made his
appointment to the supreme court as well
there were concerns about packing the
court and what they could do
to change it then and but you talk about
the future and what this might mean more
fully i've been watching the coverage
all day and listening to people's
concerns about this judgment because it
not only um you know it rolls back on
roe versus wade it takes away that right
to abortion for women but there's also
concerns about what it could mean for
access to contraception because this is
mentioned
in a and gay marriage and there's real
concerns i've
watched um american politicians today
raise real um fear actually on what
could be next you know this is a right
they are rolling back people's rights
here and i comment from nancy pelosi
where she said that american women today
have less freedom than their mothers do
you know we've all we all live in a time
where rights have been extended over
time and this feels you know this is the
united states of america and they are
rolling back on rights that women have
yeah and you're not along to some of
that polly i mean
it's hard to draw lessons from the u.s
isn't it and obviously we're a very
different country here but
is there any kind of lesson that could
be drawn from what we're seeing in the
u.s right now do you think
um
you know i actually think it's really
important that we do protect our
political discourse from kind of
assumptions that everything is the same
here you know people sometimes say that
that boris johnson's as bad as trump i
don't like boris johnson very much he's
not as bad as trump people say that
racism is uh horrific and out of control
in the united kingdom it is terrible but
it's nowhere near as bad as it is in the
united states where the numbers of of
black people killed by the police is
just
completely out of step with what happens
in the united kingdom so we do need to
be mindful that you know we actually
have a much more i think
settled set of opinions and rights for
women there are still debates at the
margin uh during lockdown for example
women were permitted to have abortion
drugs at home and there was then a
parliamentary fight to extend that um
and others were skeptical there are some
on the conservative right who'd like to
see you know the time limit for abortion
brought down um but that's a complete
world away
from you know a discourse in the united
states where there are individual states
who think that a woman should be forced
to bring a child to term even if it will
kill her even if that child is the
result of being raped by her father
absolutely right okay polly mckenzie and
rachel watson do appreciate your time